Give it up for my good friend
and yours, Whitney Cummings!
BOOM!
Aaaaahhhhhhhh
Yeah!
There's a documentary that I need you to watch immediately!
Why are you complaining about this miracle in your living room?
Turn this song off in three minutes!!
Pa pop pop, ca-crack, pop!
*baby voice* Daddy, Daddy, Daddy, Daddy
They don't deserve to see this V-neck and this d*ck!
That is a move that's illegal in the NFL
I would like a Big Beaver Magazine, please!
I paid 74 nickels for this bullsh*t!
We put it on our FACE!
We can plie down to the spelling bee
I'm on the moon!
It's like two crocodile eyes coming out of a pond.
STOP! NO!
Should we just get in the van with that guy?
AH! AH!
I feel like that was good
Can I have my ring please? *pig noises*
*scoffs* She doesn't get it!
Haha, I know. Can you believe I'm not married? Uhm